thanks to brilliant for supporting this
episode of journey to the micro cosmos
go to brilliant.org microcosmos to check
out their scientific thinking course and
get 20 off an annual premium
subscription
[Music]
when you're in the business of hunting
for microbes sometimes you have to send
some weird emails that is why james our
master of microscopes sat down one day
to send his own strange request to the
people at cor alexey a coral farm in
germany
the job of coral farms like core alexey
is to cultivate corals for people to
fill their aquariums with protecting
natural coral reefs from collection and
the process
and while farming might make it sound
like they're growing plants corals are
actually animals colonies made up of
marine invertebrates that form
spectacular structures painted with
vibrant colors
so you can imagine that there are lots
of beautiful things to seek out from
coral farms but james was not emailing
to ask about corals
james wanted something a little more
unusual and a little less desirable he
wanted to know if coralxi could check
their filter systems and send him some
of the scum that deposits there
after all we have found fascinating
organisms in fish tanks and in sync
drains why not combine the two
fortunately for us and for you the
people at core alexey were also very
curious about what their reef tanks
might reveal when put under the
microscope so of course they sent james
a bunch of stuff
in addition to corals which we will get
to in a future episode the generous team
at core alexey put together two bags of
sediment and gravel from their tanks
three large bottles of plankton cultures
some macro algae and most exciting to
james
a concrete brick
[Music]
yes you heard me correctly it just so
happened that this brick had been placed
in many of their tanks so when james got
his hands on it he was delighted to find
all sorts of interesting creatures
growing on this brick some of the
organisms he found were completely new
to him like this weird living hybrid of
spikes and puff understandably when
james first saw it he was not sure what
to make of it
but then when he zoomed in on those tiny
pointy bits he could make out the
needle-like structures called spicules
that belong to sponges
sponges are sort of like corals in that
they are invertebrates that don't move
around but they are also much more
simple than corals
this particular sponge is known either
as a pineapple sponge or a q-tip sponge
both of which are excellent names
they're found in marine waters all
around the world but they also often
hitchhike their way into aquariums
james also got the chance to record some
ciliates he had never recorded before
like the paratroomus you see here
wheeling itself across the slide
and from even closer up you can see
those individual cilia at work as they
push the organism around in circles
one of the fascinating parts of looking
at organisms that have come from
aquariums is getting to see them make
homes out of structures we don't usually
get to see in our normal pond samples
like these worm-like ciliates called
trachelocercids which are stretching in
and out of a shell they found there are
several of them inside there turning the
shell into their own little trichello
cerseid commune which makes you wonder
how they all found the shell to begin
with and how they all decided to gather
there
and then there's this ciliate swimming
in the remains of a crustacean's
carapace or shell looking just a teensy
bit lost
the structures in the canvas make for a
harsh landscape under the microscope
like these columns of icy rocks that the
ciliate has to make its way through
from other angles the landscape shifts
into a surreal crystal palace one that
seems to have temporarily trapped the
ciliate in its confines but the
carapaces that have now formed chiseled
boundaries around the ciliate were once
part of a living breathing animal a
crustacean
so
where did that crustacean go
well of course we don't know for certain
but perhaps they got eaten by this
flatworm you can see the remains of a
crustacean taking up space static in the
otherwise very wiggly body of the
flatworm
zoom in closer and you can see the
remains of the crustacean surrounded by
a mixture of yellow and brown that looks
kind of like dijon mustard of course the
flatworm has not made a tasty mustard
crustacean dish for itself those bits of
brown are actually endosymbiotic
dinoflagellates that live inside the
flatworm in exchange for providing
nutrients to the worm
this relationship mirrors the mutualism
that corals and algae exhibit as well
with corals providing protection and
photosynthesis supplies to the algae and
the algae providing nutrients and waste
removal services in return
unfortunately not all creatures are
turning to algae for a mutually
beneficial relationship
some just like to use the algae for food
like this ciliate called chlamydon whose
body is filled with its dinoflagellate
dinners and inside the sediment samples
that james studied were many gorgeous
algae eating foraminifera those hard
exteriors are home to amoebas which use
their false feet to poke out and grab
food but they're also an integral part
of marine food webs because animals like
fish will come along and eat them in
addition to the microbial worlds that
james got to explore in these samples
there were also plenty of creatures who
are by our standards a bit on the large
side like this snail spinning around in
circles we cannot speak to what these
snails are up to but it's not surprising
to find them here snails eat debris and
plant matter which makes them useful
living vacuum cleaners to help clear up
aquariums plus they're just very cool to
watch this one has an alien crawling
across the empty night sky vibe that
makes it kind of hard to look away from
and in addition to the snails there were
bristle worms in these samples that we
were very excited to see but we are
going to save that excitement for the
next episode
for all the things we know in these
samples there were some mysteries as
well for example we think this creature
might be a flatworm because it kind of
looks like a flat worm it certainly
moves like a worm but this is the
microcosmos we're talking about a place
where appearances are often deceptive
and since we cannot identify the species
we're looking at we're not even actually
sure if it's a flatworm with higher
magnification you can see these rod
structures inside of it like a bunch of
tiny little worms nested within the body
of this maybe worm
except we have no idea what those
structures are so if any of you know
what this creature is or what those
structures are please let us know in the
comments
what has stood out to us as we look
through all of these samples is just how
many different types of creatures there
are
some resemble life we found in other
bodies of water and some are things that
we may never have gotten a chance to see
if james had not taken that step to send
a strange email to a coral farm it
should hardly be surprising given that
corals support such an incredible
breadth of life in the wild but it is
still beautiful to explore that breadth
to see its smallest forms thriving
because to them
even a farm
is wild
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you to
brilliant for sponsoring this episode
brilliant features hands-on interactive
courses in science engineering computer
science and math and brilliant has
recently upped the interactivity in
their courses in their scientific
thinking course you'll dive into the
world of scientific principles by
exploring the laws of physics and
principles of engineering along the way
you'll gain the understanding and
insight needed to start looking at the
world in a different way the courses are
designed for people of all levels so you
can jump in at any point and work your
way to mastery and brilliant courses are
also available offline using their ios
and android app so if you are traveling
or have spotty internet connection you
will still be able to keep learning
if you're interested in learning more
you can get 20 off an annual premium
subscription at brilliant.org
microcosmos
the folks whose names you're seeing come
up on the screen right now you know who
they are they are the people who make it
possible for us to send a weird email to
a coral farm and get a bunch of stuff
mailed to us so that we can show you the
beautiful diversity of all that is going
on
inside of a brick
what a cool thing we are all doing
together thank you so much for your
support and if you're interested in that
you can check it out at patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss and why wouldn't you you can check
out jam and germs on instagram and if
you want to see more from us there is
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
[Music]